[Music]
hi I'm Cano and here's how to make my
favorite fried Kenyan street foods
mandazi are these little triangular
shaped Donuts they are eaten across the
entire country but the way people make
them vary slightly depending on what
spices they use and what kind of lemon
are they is some people don't use any
spices some use cinnamon I like using
cardamom cardamom is definitely more
common in the coastal part of Kenya but
honestly it is one of my favorite spices
to bake with this type of mandazi really
varies depending on which part of Kenya
you're in on the coast it's really
common to you something like coconut
milk where inland
it's actually really normal just to use
water or even milk good mandazi
unfortunately are really tough to come
by what you really want from mandazi is
it to be soft mandazi can be really
tough it made improperly
what can lead to tough mandazi is not
using a good leavener or an expired
leavener or not having too much liquid
if you can find in the market a really
soft mandazi I am telling you you have
hit the jackpot you can eat mandazi any
time of day but it is most commonly had
in the morning just as you would any
other doughnut it's most commonly served
with Kenyan coffee or chai mandazi and
chai are the most perfect breakfast
match you can have it plain some people
will put a little bit of jam on it it's
really whatever you like but mandazi on
their own are so addictive and so
delicious and it's very hard to have
just one but Gia's are an Indian import
to Kenya they are really common to have
in the major cities so you'll have it in
Mombasa as well as Street markets in
Nairobi the blend the spice is used to
make bhaji is also varies from person to
person I like mine just to have like a
little hints of spice there's many
different types of but Gia's you can
have you can have it with onions and
like herbs or some fried greens but my
favorite and
probably one of the most common ones are
potato the perfect size I cut them is an
eighth of an inch that way they're still
firm and they're not too thin like
potato chip if your potatoes are thick
they might not be all the way done
before your batter burns they are
insanely delicious and packs with so
much flavor it's served usually with
different types of chutneys I like a
tomato chutney you can find chips AKA
french fries all over the entire country
and kind of people say chips instead of
fries because people speak British
English rather than American English now
I've seen masala chips made three
different ways I've seen a dry masala
rub where it's a dry spice blend that's
tossed into the chips which are really
similar to just like a seasoned french
fry however my favorite type of masala
chips are the ones that are tossed into
a sauce
now this sauce is really simple to make
using just a couple ingredients that are
the biggest variation I've seen in
making masala chips comes down to the
tomato I like using fresh tomatoes only
because I prefer a less sweet masala
chip but it's really common to find
vendors using a ketchup instead of the
tomatoes I will note though that Kenyan
ketchup is not the same as American
ketchup man it is hard to beat that
whether you call them samosas or
sambusas these little triangle shape
pastries are found all over East Africa
the Middle East all the way to India the
Kenyan style of samosa uses a really
really thin dough and is most commonly
filled with spiced beef Kenya loves its
meat yama toma which is Kenyan barbecue
is the national food of the country you
asked most Kenyans what their favorite
food is the answer will be meat samosas
can be found in street markets but
honestly the place I have the most are
gas stations penny gas stations are more
than just a place to fill up your petrol
a lot of gas stations actually
restaurants or cafes attached to them
there you can find really delicious Toma
chicken and chips as well as samosas and
I'll tell you probably the best most
I've ever had came from a gas station
one thing you've noticed about a lot of
street food in Kenya is that even street
vendors will have places for you to sit
down and enjoy your food of course there
are places where you can kind of have
portable items where you can like walk
and eat but it's not that common the
culture to walk while eating doesn't
matter whether you're in a market or a
restaurant people prefer to sit down and
enjoy their meals it's very common to
find street vendors with small tables
and chairs right next to their stall for
you to enjoy the food to actually serve
it on reusable plates rather than
disposable ware because doesn't matter
whether you have walls around the
kitchen or not people like sitting that
enjoy meals together the most
labor-intensive part of samosa making is
really making the dough from scratch
it's a very simple dough just with some
flour water and a touch of oil but it
can be quite time-consuming so a little
hack my family and I have our egg roll
wrappers I kid you not they work
fantastically because they are super
thin all you have to do is cut the egg
roll wrapper in half diagonally and use
it in the exact same way you might not
have time to make your wrappers from
scratch and it's totally okay people
love them regardless of what the wrapper
is made out of my favorite part of
eating the Kenyan samosa is the squeeze
of lime in the end the flavors
complement each other so perfectly I'm
telling you it seems like an optional
thing but it will take your samosas to
the next level
I kid you not I hope you give some of
these recipes a try at home and I hope
you enjoy them as much as I do
oh yes